I guess what can you do you can laugh  you can laugh or you cry about it 100  there's a lot of people that you know  get upset about things that they read  and stuff and it's like look you can be  angry about it but it's not going to  change it like you so you getting upset  about something that you saw on the  Internet isn't going to change the  conditions in the world one bit and I I  mean like I'm not super stoic but I do  like follow like stoicism pages and  that's one of the things that Stokes  talk about like only let the things that  you can actually change affect you and  like the things that you can't change  like just try not to let them ruin your  day because you can't do anything about  them